pour éviter les accidents les shadoks
ont décidé de ranger la terre mais les
déménageurs shadoks n'y comprennent rien
ils ne sont pas assez éduqués et du quai
les shader oui malheureusement c'était
pas une chose facile
les cerveaux des shadoks ont effet avait
une capacité est tout à fait limité il
ne comportait dans tout que quatre cas
et encore c'était pas toujours vrai
parce que bien souvent il y en avait
deux bouchées pour remplir les cases
déjà c'était pas facile et je la prenais
un certain temps ces salons que comme on
sait la difficulté parce que collet case
était plein il y avait plus de place et
le chat d'oc
on ne pouvait plus rien lui apprendre si
on essayait quand même alors
obligatoirement il y avait une case qui
se vidait pour faire de la place de
sorte que quand shadoks avec une tête
plein vous l'êtes à pondre quelque chose
il fallait qu'ils en oublient une autre
exemple c'est un shadok avait appris à
marcher avec une case et que plus tard
il est a pris trois mots avec les trois
autres cases et bien si en plus on
voulait lui apprendre à faire du vélo
le château qui ne savait plus marcher
commune avec quatre cases évidemment les
shadoks ne connaissais pas plus que
quatre mots c'était gars du zoo et me
hu